Welcome back to human emotion.
So I want you to start out by first remembering a time that you felt a strong
emotion.
Now pause for a second in this exercise and really focus on what made you feel
that emotion in the first place.
Was it an image you saw a movie you recently watched,
a conversation you had with a friend or a partner?
So these are some of the questions we try to think about when we're trying to
trigger emotions in the lab as emotion researchers.
And we try to ask ourselves,
how can we trigger and create these same feelings we all know and experience in
our everyday life in the lab when we try to study emotion.
So the spot exercise is really intended to get you to think about the kinds of
emotions you experience and how if you were a scientist in this field,
you might try to recreate those very same feelings in a research study.
So one of the most authoritative handbooks on this topic and that will really
guide much of what we discussed today is called the handbook of emotion
elicitation and assessment by James Cone.
And John J out.
And so this is also included in your weekly readings.
So what we're going to be doing here today is discussing some of the common
tools and methods of human emotion.
So today we'll be focusing specifically on the laboratory elicitation of emotion
by learning about all the different kinds of cool tools and methods that we can
use to try to understand and quantify emotion.
So imagine yourself here in the laboratory as an emotion scientist.
What are you going to do?
How are you going to measure it?
So,
and what we're going to be doing today is starting our first part of a three
part series on emotion elicitation and measurement.
Really getting at what actually makes us emotional in the first place,
and how can we study it.
So our roadmap today will go as follows.
We'll start by discussing several tools and methods used to elicit emotion,
and then we'll move on to our takeaway questions for this lecture,
covering the three broad content areas that you should have gained after
watching this lecture.
And finally we'll move on to our expert interview or announced figure in the
area of emotion elicitation and the way that we measure it.
So let's start with some of the tools and methods.
And before we do that,
what I'd like to do is focus on three key emotion processes that these different
tools can help us elicit or tap into.
So you already see the first one here,
which is emotion reactivity.
So this is one of the core processes and we try to elicit emotion that we focus
on.
So emotion reactivity can be defined as the type magnitude and duration of a
response to internal and external environmental accused that have significance
for our personal goals.
The second important process we try to elicit as researchers and scientists of
emotion is what's called emotion regulation.
So this has been defined as the processes by which individuals influence which
emotions they have,
when they have them,
and how they experience and express these emotions.
Finally,
we have emotional understanding.
So this is different from reactivity in regulation is it's more focusing on the
knowledge that people have about,
you know,
whether we or other people are experiencing emotions.
So can we accurately pick up on her own emotions in the moment and can we
actually see and detect them and other people?
So
we'll be focusing on eight broad domains of emotional dissertation.
And today we'll start with the first four at the top that are highlighted in
red.
And what we're going to be doing is moving through each of these tools,
defining them,
providing an example,
and discussing some of the relative strengths and limitations of each of these
tools.
So let's first start with some clips.
Yeah.
So we know that emotions and real life often occur in response to dynamic and
external visual and auditory stimuli.
So film clips are really nice and that they have a high degree of ecological
validity in this respect,
which helps us generalize the kinds of emotions that we see when we have people
view films to maybe more everyday life emotional experiences.
Some clips were first used to elicit emotion from the 1960s in studying stress
responses.
And since then there's been a huge development and really putting forth a wide
repertoire of film clips that can be used to elicit all kinds of distinct
emotions that range from amusement to anger,
contentment,
disgust,
fear,
sadness,
surprise,
and even a neutral comparison or baseline state.
So you see here in this slide are an example of some key prototypical films that
researchers often use to elicit feelings of happiness,
sadness,
and a more baseline neutral state using a screen saver.
And you have participants,
as you can see,
the man in the bottom left corner who will come into the laboratory,
sit at a computer desk and view these films on a monitor.
Yeah.
So let me show you a brief example of a happy film clip that's widely used in
emotion research.
So this is,
uh,
a film clip to picking Sarah Hughes,
winning the Olympic gold medal.
And you'll see the excitement and happiness as she learns of her,
you know,
fantastic award.
And this has been shown to reliably licit high arousal positive states such as
excitement.
And Joy
[inaudible]
Aye.
So let's contrast this.
Um,
so we'll now contrast this with one of the most common sad films.
And this is a film taken from the Champ to picking a young boy crying and
mourning over the death of his father.
And this film has been reliably used by researchers to elicit high degrees of
sadness.
So take a moment to watch this film and see how you feel as you watch the scene
unfold.
Your aunt.
Yeah,
yeah,
please.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh
Wake up.
Oh,
what?
No,
what,
sorry.
Ooh,
he got to go home.
There.
You see.
So there you see an example of some of the most commonly use positive and
negative films in the field.
So when we summarize film clips as a tool to elicit emotion,
where are we at?
Well,
it seems that films are incredibly good at eliciting the three domains of
emotion processes.
We started out with emotional reactivity,
looking at people's responses to the film emotion regulation,
looking at how they may try to either up regulate or amplify or downregulate or
deintensify their emotion as well as emotion understanding by asking
participants how do they think the people in those film clips felt the of film
clips or that they have good ecological validity.
They're dynamic and they're embedded within a social context where most of our
richest emotional experiences occur.
The disadvantages of films though is that they require high cognitive demands on
the participant.
They can be thematically complex and they can be difficult for some participants
to follow throughout.
And we know that films can't elicit elicit the full array of emotions.
For example.
To date,
we have no good film clips that can reliably elicit anger as an example.
So now let's move on to static photos.
So by photos,
what we're known in the field as some of the most,
you know,
robust images that can elicit emotions come from this repository of emotional
images known as the international aspect of picture system or I apps.
The I apps consists of more than 700 colored images of different kinds of
situations selected due to their ability to reliably list robust,
positive,
negative,
and more neutral emotion states.
And here's some examples that you can see here from the ops image system.
So these are nice because they've been widely used,
they're publicly available and have standardized ratings for both arousal level
as well as how positive or negatively valence they are.
So I'll walk you through just a few examples of them now.
So in addition to these three you see here,
this is a positive image from the IOP system.
Another high arousal positive image of a very negative image.
This is one of the erotica,
high arousal positive images.
And ideally this would be a neutral image for most people unless you have a
special relationship with file cabinets.
Um,
and this is another negative image designed to illicit low arousal,
negative emotions like sadness.
This is seen as a positive image of a peaceful landscape and another positive
image of,
you know,
dolphins playing in the water with a soccer ball.
So in addition to the iops photos,
another category of photos that are frequently used to elicit emotion include
images of human faces,
displaying prototypical expressions of emotion.
As you can see here,
the theory behind this is that emotion expressions in the human face are a
robust illicit or of emotion expressed to other people.
So commonly used databases for emotional photos include the facial action coding
system repertoire by Paul Ekman.
Um,
this is an example of the kinds of images you might see in a Paul Ekman system.
as well as more recent developments to try to expand the kinds of images we have
beyond these kind of six basic emotions of anger,
see,
you know,
fear,
happiness,
sadness,
disgust to include more subtle and socially complex emotions by Dacher Keltner
and colleagues at Berkeley.
So they've included images that express,
you know,
Co coy smiles,
compassion,
desire,
and even pride.
So when we summarize static photos,
again just like films fairy,
fantastic,
stimulate to elicit reactivity regulation and you can use them to index emotion,
understanding the advantages relative to films or that they actually have
relatively low cognitive demand as well as low language demand.
There isn't any sort of script that people have to follow and interpret.
The disadvantages though is that there's a limited range of emotions that you
can elicit using photos.
The I app system that we saw is often biased towards a certain narrow category
of emotions,
like disgust,
that really nasty photo.
You saw the teeth with all the tumors amusement.
So you see the dolphins playing with a soccer ball and sexual arousal,
although some people argue that the photos like the ones you saw Alyssa horror
amusement than arousal.
Um,
and also when we think about the images of human facial expressions,
they are often these kind of caricature ask exaggerated expressions of fear or
happiness and they may not really be generalizable to the more subtle kinds of
emotion expressions we see in our everyday life.
So those are films and photos.
Now let's turn to relived emotions or autobiographical memories of our own
personalized emotional life events.
So here with relived emotions,
what we're really trying to do is get inside someone's head and have them recall
the kinds of emotional memories that are most salient to them.
So an example of how to elicit relived emotions includes using a semi structured
interview to prompt participants to try to retrieve memories of a specific event
that elicited emotion.
And once they recall an event and they're identified,
they're asked to try to now go back in time and relive the memories as strongly
as possible,
almost to put yourself in the shoes of where you were and who you were with when
you felt that emotion.
Maybe it was here like this young girl Christmas Day and getting the most
awesome present possible.
So when we think of relived emotions,
there's two categories that we can really focus on.
One,
our autobiographical memories.
So like what we just talked about,
these are the personally relevant emotional memories from our own lives.
So it can be asking you to recall maybe the happiest moment in your life or the
saddest moment in your life.
This is distinct from what are called shared memories.
So these are shared memories like nine 11 of you know,
significant historic or group events.
And these are often talked about as flashbulb memories.
So these are things that you share with a collective group as opposed to Autobio
autobiographical memories that are really about your own individualized
experience.
So the processes that we lived,
emotions can really tap into our reactivity,
looking at how we respond to recalling emotions and regulations.
So how can we try to increase or decrease the emotions we feel when we're
thinking about these memories?
The advantages of relived emotions is unlike films,
uh,
and photos for that matter.
These are more personally salient.
There are about your own emotion experience.
And so as a result,
they can be more engaging for the person you know,
to get into as opposed to watching films or images of other people experiencing
emotional events.
And so for that reason,
they're thought thoughts have what's called good ecological validity,
meaning that they map on really well to real world or real life emotional
experiences and events.
Some of the disadvantages,
however,
is that there are more radiographic meaning.
They vary from person to person that you bring into the lab.
So it's hard to standardize these across participants because each of us have
our own unique emotional lives and our own unique emotional memories.
And so you know,
this is something that you always have to think about when you're using these
kinds of stimuli is that each person you bring in is essentially going to
generate a different memory from the person before or after them.
Also,
you know,
Azure,
we're trying,
trying to recall an emotional memory.
It has high cognitive or memory demand.
So it can be difficult for people on the one hand to really internally visualize
a memory in great detail and then also feel the emotion,
right?
It's almost like trying to draw a really complex picture but also feel the
emotions that the picture in genders.
So this can be a difficulty that's often brought up with relived memories.
So we talked about films,
photos,
relived emotions,
and now we're going to turn to dyadic interactions here.
What we're really looking at,
our interactions between people.
So dyadic interactions can include differences in who the people are.
So it can be between two people who are spouses to family members,
a caregiver and the person they're taking care of,
two friends or even to strangers.
And usually these kinds of interactions settings consists of having people come
into the lab,
sit down,
like you see the people here on the slide and engage in brief conversations,
maybe between five and 10 minutes proceeded by a silent baseline period
beforehand.
And the conversation topics can range from neutral everyday context such as
events of the day,
positive topics such as discussing things that people enjoy doing together or
negative context.
So with romantic partners,
a can discussing relationship problems or between strangers,
it can be sharing a time of personal suffering or loss.
So when you're doing these kinds of tasks at the end you can tap into emotion
experience asking each partner how did they feel at the end of that conversation
as well as emotion perception.
So how do you think your partner's feeling right now after that conversation?
And this enables you to get at not only the own the individual's experience,
but their ability to accurately gauge or what was called empathic accuracy.
How good are they at really mapping on an understanding the emotions of other
people.
So the summary here for dyadic interactions is that indeed it maps on to all
three key emotion to s discussed reactivity,
regulation and understanding.
It is perhaps even the best at emotion understanding cause you're really getting
in the moment in Vivo interactions and asking them with a real human being,
how well are they at picking up on their emotions and comparing it to what that
other person actually reports healing.
The advantages are that it has good ecological validity and that it occurs in
more naturalistic social context.
So this is something that we can say might likely map on to how the person
emotionally operates around other people in their own life.
The disadvantages,
much like relived emotional memories is that again,
it's,
it's pretty idiographic.
It will vary from diet to diet,
what they talk about and the kinds of emotions that they experience.
It's not easy to standardize across dyads.
It's not easy to get the exact two people in every experiment and ensure that
exactly what they talk about is,
you know,
mapped content wise.
And also we know that people's emotional responses get influenced by both
members of a dyad.
So the way that one person responds or reacts will shift and change the emotions
of the other person in the dyadic membership.
So it's a little bit messy and that you don't have all the rigorous experimental
control that you have with films or pictures or even memories to that extent.
But in many ways it most easily translates into the kinds of emotions we really
feel when we're having conversations with people in our everyday lives,
be it our friends,
our partners,
or our colleagues.
So we've talked about films,
static photos,
relived emotions and dyadic interactions.
And in our next lecture we'll touch on the bottom four here looking at the
another sort of realm of emotion elicitation tools.
So what I want to now do is turn to our takeaway questions mapping the kind of
key conceptual things that you should have gained out of this lecture today.
The first asked what were the four emotional elicitation tools covered today?
Second,
which of the three emotional processes did each of these four tools target?
And finally,
what are the strengths and limitations of each of the tools discussed today?
And now we'll turn to our expert interview with a fantastic knowledgeable
scholar in the field of emotional elicitation and measurement and this is part
of our experts in emotion interview series through Yale University.
Will be speaking today with Dr John Jb Allen on emotion elicitation.
Dr. Allen received his phd from the University of Minnesota and is currently a
distinguished professor of psychology,
cognitive science and neuroscience at the University of Arizona.
Dr. Allen is an expert in emotional elicitation and has co edited the handbook
of emotional elicitation.
His well known research program involves using psychophysiological tools to
understand the etiology and treatment of both mood and anxiety disorders.
He has published over 120 scientific papers,
received numerous grants and awards for his research that include the early
career award for the Society for psychophysiological research,
as well as his passion for teaching,
including the graduate college and Professional Education,
teaching and mentoring award and designation as a university distinguished
professor.
In addition to his expertise in emotion,
he's also an avid mountain biker and Eunice cyclist.
So I now turn to a very special experts in emotion interview with Doctor John J
B Allen on emotion elicitation.